première si vous intéresser à la
politique vous reste avec nous l lundi
politique
gaël le dantec et myëlle macro et
edouard philippe avancée ils font voter
leurs réformes au parlement forts de
leur large majorité en marche de temps
en temps l'opposition réussi à montrer
qu'elle existe et même parfois très
rarement il faut le dire à faire reculer
le gouvernement notre invité était à la
tête d'une de ces fronde réussi la
semaine dernière à propos d'un
aménagement du littoral outre mer nous
expliquera de quoi il s'agissait
définitivement dans l'opposition elle
doit composer cependant avec des
éléments très macro nist du parti
socialiste dont elle porte les couleurs
ses combats au parlement son
positionnement politique son avenir en
la réunion sont au menu jusqu'à 19
heures
erika barrage député socialiste
conseillère municipale de saint denis
est l'invité de lundi politique sur la
première émission que vous pouvez suivre
en vidéo sur notre site internet
les cabarets bon soir dans ça merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation fin
dans l'actualité il ya depuis ce matin
la visite à la réunion du secrétaire
d'état à la transition écologique
sébastien lecornu on va revenir en
détail sur les différents dossiers qui
concernent son ministère parce que il y
en a pas mal mais globalement qu'est ce
que vous attendez vous de cette visite
mes côtés j'ai regardé son programme
d'abord la transition écologique c'est
un sujet très important parce que
derrière la transition écologique c'est
en fait c'est de savoir comment on
protège notre terre pour pouvoir
survivre pour pas disparaître
donc c'est quand même très important
quand on sait qu'on va avoir un million
d'habitants il faut rien lâcher là
dessus parce qu'autrement quand on se
réveillera dans 10 ans 15 ans et qu'on
n'aura pas maîtriser notre aménagement
du territoire on aura perdu notre parc
national nos rivages nos paysages
et ça ce serait une catastrophe tout ça
et puis j'attends de lui de garantie sur
ce sujet là non je pense que d'abord une
écoute parce que la loi nous donne aux
élus locaux je veux dire aussi beaucoup
de capacités et de pouvoir par les lois
de décentralisation successives par la
loi transition énergétique que nous
avions voté lors du dernier quinquennat
moi j'étais rapporteur sur la partie
outre-mer où on a installé une
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
pour pouvoir construire au niveau
régional une stratégie de maîtrise de
l'énergie
de production de l'énergie propre ça va
avec la transition écologique donc on a
des pouvoirs ici donnée par la loi des
nos élus locaux mais on doit avoir aussi
effectivement une écoute attentive des
représentants du gouvernement pour qu à
un moment donné ce que nous souhaitons
localement trouve un soutien financier
n'est pas que financier législatif et
réglementaire pour qu'on puisse mettre
en oeuvre tous les projets que nous
avons sur le territoire parmi les
dossiers liés à l'environnement et à la
question des carrières destine aux
chantiers la nouvelle route du littoral
c'est par votre domaine forcément tant
que député mais vous êtes évidemment
concerné le schéma départemental des
carrières modifié par la préfecture n'a
pas respecté les règles concernant les
études de environnementale a donc été
annulée est ce que vous pensez vous
erika barrage qu'il faut passer outre
ces autorisations ces règlements qui
peuvent êtres qui peuvent paraître
tatillon sur le respect d'environnement
et où est qu'il faut avancer coûte que
coûte ou est ce que il faut en profiter
pour tout remettre à plat sur ce dossier
quitte à prendre un peu de retard
vous savez c'est toujours très compliqué
parce que derrière ce ce dossier vous
voyez bien et les réunionnais qui nous
écoutent voit bien qu'il y a souvent des
questionnements politiques et peut-être
un procès de dire il ya telle ou telle
position parce qu'on était contre telle
ou telle personne je voudrais moi
puisque la question est posée vraiment
dire les choses le plus simplement
possible le plus objectivement possible
on a un grand chantier qui a été voulu
par les réunionnais puisque il est
consécutive un vote régional mais il se
trouve que la réalisation totale de ce
projet a engrangé des procédures et
aussi des besoins en termes de roche et
donc du coup une question en termes de
haut en termes de schémas de des
carrières donc quand on est à ce stade
là pour revenir au point de départ de
notre discussion
il faut toujours se demander est ce que
si nous faisons tel ou tel l'acte qui
écorche trop notre terre réunionnaise
est ce que elle va pouvoir survivre elle
ce qu'elle ne va pas réagir trop
violemment pour que après de sorte
qu'elle nous met
nous en danger je prends un exemple si
je pars je passe un sur les problèmes
juridiques ont été évoqués certainement
parler par les juges mais je parle en
terme environnemental
il n'est pas inutile vraiment de nous
dire est ce que les décisions que nous
allons prendre maintenant en 2018 demain
andy 2019
est ce que cette décision là de façon de
plus objectif et scientifique possible
n'auront pas de répercussion de main sur
des risques d'inondation plus grande sur
plus grand sur des risques
d'effondrement de tel ou tel falaise
plus grand jeu il faut se poser ces
questions de façon objective parce que
derrière c'est la vie des gens qui est
mise en danger
voilà donc vraiment je pense que il faut
trouver cet équilibre entre finir un
projet qui engage la région réunion et
protéger la vie de nos populations dans
les 5 10 15 20 50 ans qui viennent on
est intervenu à la vie sur tranché sur
la question
je ne suis pas satisfait je ne suis pas
scientifique tout ce que je sais c'est
que les magistrats ont eu une position
est que les magistrats en dit le droit
et quand le droit est dit dans cette
république le droit est fait pour être
respecté il ya également dans
l'actualité environnementale
cette question des restaurants de plage
de saint gilles agite en ce moment il a
fallu des manifestations pour que les
règles concernant la protection du
domaine maritime public soit respecté
ses respects ses restaurants vont devoir
quitter la plage voilà à la fin du mois
une nouvelle bataille va peut-être
s'engager pour savoir s'ils doivent
complètement disparaître ou simplement
reculé mais il semblerait d'après en
tout cas le rapporteur de l'enquêté
publique que la zone de l'arrière plage
sera aussi inconstructibles très prend
le mont déclaré par inconstructibles
part par là des halles est-ce qu'il faut
privilégier là encore le respect de
l'environnement et l'accès à la plage
pour tous ou est-ce qu'il faut aussi
penser développement économique emploi
développement touristique
si on fait du développement économique
sans respecter l'environnement et que
l'environnement est encore vivant la
terre est encore vivant
si on la grèce de trop elle réagi vous
aurez fait du développement économique
et la mer va reprendre le dessus et va
monter et va détruire les choses vous
aurez gagné quoi rien du tout rien
qu'est ce que vous dites à ordures aux
restaurateurs
moi je dis qu'il faut d'abord ce que je
veux dire c'est que toutes ces
situations qui sont le résultat de très
très très très nombreuses années de
laisser faire
c'est bien qu'elle qu'elle cesse et
c'est bien qu'on remette ensemble la
question de ce que nous vous comment
nous voulons aménager la terre
réunionnaise c'est une question qui se
pose à tous ceux à tous les réunionnais
et nous devons tous avoir un point de
vue là dessus on doit respecter ce
rivage on doit respecter nos paysages
on doit respecter notre environnement
mais on doit aussi savoir aménagé pour
que nous puissions développer notre
territoire pour pouvoir avoir de
l'économie et créer de l'emploi
ensuite dans le même axe je pense qu'il
ya aussi beaucoup de métiers que nous ne
développons pas aujourd'hui et qu'ils
font qui font la synthèse entre ça entre
tous à l'économie bleus l'économie verte
sûr que vous dites aujourd'hui au
serveur le aux cuisiniers de se
reconvertir en devenant mais j'avais
leur nom je vais revenir sur v je finis
mon raisonnement sur la nouvelle
économie
toutes ces nouvelles économies qui
associe la préservation de
l'environnement et la production
économique
il faut que nous puissions vraiment
développer ces économies ce que nous ne
faisons pas on met tout ça on communique
beaucoup mais on ne fait pas ensuite ce
que je dis aux restaurateurs et
à ceux qui sont installés au bar etc et
aussi aux pouvoirs publics parce que ça
n'est pas au restaurateur trouvé la
solution c'est aux pouvoirs publics
c'est à dire à l'état et aux communes de
pouvoir proposer à ceux qui ont des
activités qui sont nécessaires si on
veut aussi avoir du tourisme si on veut
avoir des touristes il faut quand même
que les touristes puissent manger puisse
boire
voilà mais est-ce que c'est toujours
dans des situations opposées
soit on est tous sur la plage et on ne
respecte pas la règle ou on est très
loin de la plage et ça peut pas se faire
quand même
je pense qu'il y à un juste milieu
respecter le droit et permettre à ces
restaurateurs de travailler et à ses
salariés d'avoir de continuer à faire
leur métier
à propos de littérale de littoral vous
avez très fièrement annoncé vous aviez
réussi à faire reculer le gouvernement
sur un des aspects de la loi et lors la
loi sur le logement et l'aménagement
finalement c'est un amendement un peu
surprise qui concerne l aménagement du
territoire de quoi s'agissait-il
précisément et et pourquoi est-ce que
c'est finalement c'est important d'avoir
réussi à faire reculer le gouvernement
sur ce point je sais pas si j'étais très
fier audio vous l'avez vous avez
communiqué ah ben il vaut mieux
communiquer quand on fait quelque chose
chez d'accord et puis il faut
communiquer pour d'abord dire qu'on a
réalisé et puis dire ce qu'il y avait
derrière cette affaire là parce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a eu dans
la loi est lent donc c'est une loi qui
traite de tout le sujet de l'aménagement
du territoire et de la production de
logements pour aller vite et du logement
social mais il ya beaucoup de sujets là
dedans et donc dans cette loi sur
laquelle j'ai quelques amendements au
dernier moment donc vendredi il ya dix
jours je découvre qui a eu un amendement
qui a été déposée par
la majorité en marche et sans qu'il y
ait des d'identification ultramarines
c'est à dire pas de députés ultramarins
là dedans et quand je lis l'amendement
je vois qu'ils concernent l'outre-mer la
corse et les îles bretonnes parler vite
et on voit que on va être dans une
réglementation assouplies pour qu'il y
ait de la construction de bâtiments
d'intérêt collectif sur des territoires
sans ne plus passer par l'avis des élus
locaux et je me dis mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cet amendement jamais ici
personne ne m'a parlé de ça j'interroge
quelques collègues des autres
territoires mme dia non mais non on n'a
pas demandé et en regardant je je je me
rends compte que en laissant passer un
tel amendement on allait retirer le
pouvoir d'aménagement à nos élus locaux
donc l inverse de tout ce que je viens
de vous dire est qu'on allait pouvoir
mettre sur
un terrain je prends par exemple voyez
le vvf à saint gilles est bas au niveau
du vvf de saint gilles a on a les deux
mains pouvoir mettre par exemple une
usine de traitement de déchets dans le
jeu vous imaginez une usine de
traitement de déchets là par exemple
sans que personne ait donné la vie de
rien sur ce truc là je dis non mais ça
c'est pas possible
j'avais à votre connaissance des
arrière-pensées réunionnaise dans ce
dossier réunionnaise je sais pas mais
j'ai cru comprendre vous savez qu'à
force de fouiller parce que j'aime bien
aller fouiller les choses une fois que
je tiens un sujet j'aime bien
reconnaître pourquoi ces s'est passé
d'ailleurs en séance j'ai demandé au
ministre mais pourquoi vous avez fait ça
pourquoi vous avez fait ça si vous
voulez faire quelque chose demande et
nous on va vous dire s'il ya des projets
sur lequel on a besoin de vous donc j'ai
cru comprendre que sur d'autres
territoires il y avait des projets en
tout cas embrouilles et qui nécessitait
que est liée à un véritable
assouplissement de la réglementation
pour qu'il se fasse mais on ne peut pas
laisser les choses se faire en catimini
comme ça sans avoir notre notre avis et
surtout en laissant partir à vau l'eau
la maîtrise de l'aménagement de notre
territoire et la protection de notre
territoire
lorsqu'il pouvait trancher que nicolas
hulot finalement vous félicite pour
avoir retoqué
et ouais non mais ça ccc ccc comme un
maintien wac parce que aux sorties de
cet amendement de cette de ce débat où
du coup j'ai rallié tout le monde et le
gouvernement a admis qu'ils avaient
quand même un petit souci qu'il votait
faisait voter mon amendement ce qui est
quand même incroyable parce que le
gouvernement donne un avis favorable à
mon un moment que l'opposition il a
reculé mais et donc j'ai eu un contact
avec le effectivement le cabinet de
nicolas hulot qui a sollicité que nous
puissions nous voir donc on organise ce
rendez-vous demi fierté également demie
seulement parce que pourquoi pourquoi
des produits dégagement vous n'avez pas
obtenu l'adoption d'un amendement pour
empêcher l'écoulement de ces produits
sur le marché un ennemi vous avez obtenu
que les services de la concurrence se
penche un peu plus sérieusement sur sur
sur ce dossier vous croyez que ça pourra
avoir effectivement un impact là on peut
rappeler de très rapidement c'est quoi
ces produits dégagements ce que des
produits alimentaires qui sont écoulés
outre-mer ouais alors tu as deux de 2,3
points alors les produits également vous
avez bien défini ce sont des produits
j'aime bien dire dégagé sont vraiment
dégagé et quand je dis ça ça veut dire
que le marché français le revenant et en
a pas là bas il y en a pas sur
l'hexagone ya pas dans les supermarchés
hexagonaux d'ailleurs je disais à mes
collègues mais vous vous en avez vous en
avez pas pourquoi vous en avez pas
manour pourquoi vous envoyer chez nous
personne n'a répondu bien sûr
et donc on nous envoie des produits qui
viennent on sait par où dans des
conditions de production
environnementale et sociale voilà et qui
détruisent sur tous nos produits sont
des choses que tout comme une norme pas
forcément pourquoi parce que on peut
prendre prenons l'exemple d'un pool et
il est produit je ne sais pas où ils
arrivent par accords commerciaux en
europe dans un pays européen quelconque
il subit une transformation c'est à dire
qu'on coupe les cuisses et on congèle
les cuisses il devient un produit
européen et après les dégager chez nous
et nous on a mis dans la loi égalité
réelle outre-mer une disposition qui
donne l'autorisation au préfet de
négocier avec les producteurs locaux et
les grandes surfaces
la maîtrise de l'entrée de ces produits
si on peut dire c'est à dire que le
préfet à un moment donné négocié parce
que y voit qu'un a trop et dit non mais
on va s'arrêter là maintenant vous
renvoyer ces produits là on n'en veut
plus sur le territoire donc le travail
en préfecture et déjà commencé donc ça
c'est dans la loi égalité réelle dans la
loi agricole qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et eu tout un débat sur le relèvement du
seuil minimum de revente
je passe dans les détails mais pourquoi
la et
c'est un minimum de revendre j'ai voulu
qu'il ne soit pas appliquée aux produits
de dégagement c'est pour ça que le
produit de dégagement est revenue dans
les débats et je n'ai pas gagné cette
bataille mais d'abord j'ai mis ce sujet
en séance
j'ai eu rufin le député rufin qui monte
en réseau avec moi j'ai eu le modem qui
est monté au créneau avec moi j'ai eu
l'art les républicains qui est venu me
rejoindre donc on a quand même fait un
vrai débat là dessus donc les gens ont
pris conscience que ce qui se passait
était pas bien et le ministre a dit bon
écoute et sur cet aspect là on va
demander une enquête de l'autorité de la
concurrence est très important parce que
l'autorité de la concurrence est déjà
intervenu sur beaucoup de dossiers dont
des dossiers sur le numérique
et quand les choses ne se font pas comme
elles doivent se faire il met des
amendes et il ya des enquêtes qui sont
publiques donc sur le front du beagle
mais si si si c'est légal ça continuera
oui mais là on va savoir si combien sont
dégagées est-ce que c'est dégagé
massivement et combien de sur combien de
produits sont dégagées et ça me
permettra de remonter au créneau à
l'assemblée nationale pour parler encore
de mes produits de dégagement et poussé
la préfecture je sais que la préfecture
travaille là dessus en ce moment pour
que l' on limite l'entrée de ces
produits dégagement mais je voudrais que
ça aille plus vite et de façon plus
musclée
j'ai demandé au ministre d'ailleurs
qu'est il active tout ça les syndicats
agricoles nous avons la fdsea que vous
avez rencontré récemment ne veut pas
évidemment que ceux produits par exemple
en concurrence par contre elle vient du
glyphosate
elle veut bien continuer à utiliser des
produits qui devraient être interdits
dans les années qui viennent tant qu'il
n'y a pas de produits de remplacement
c'est un peu compliqué vous c'est quoi
votre position sur ce sujet épineux du
glyphosate dans l'agriculture
ça aussi c'est un projet épineux parce
qu'on ne veut pas y répondre
parce qu'on ne veut pas y répondre parce
que pour répondre à au sujet du
glyphosate ça veut dire que l'on met
rapidement les choses en met tout le
monde au travail pour qu'on puisse avoir
des produits qui soient plus adapté que
le glyphosate parce que le glyphosate et
nous fait du mal et il faut qu'à un
moment donné on puisse proposer aux
agriculteurs autre chose que du
glyphosate
pour que encore une fois on parle de la
santé des gens là on parle pas de d'une
production économique c'est plus que ça
on parle de votre santé la santé de vos
enfants
et donc il faut qu'on puisse leur
proposer autre chose or tant qu'on est
pas de date butoir
par rapport au glyphosate il n'y aura
pas de deux propositions différentes du
cercueil pour ce soit dans la loi moi
j'aurais préféré que ce soit dans la loi
pour parce que vous savez c'est ce que
je disais à la ministe de muriel
pénicaud sur l'amendement sur
l'amendement formation professionnelle
quelquefois être dans la loi ce ça ne
crée pas du droit forcément mais ça pose
les choses et ça permet d'avoir un
raccord qui impulsent date façon de
faire et je pense que mettre dans la loi
aurait permis d'impulser une autre
vision des choses et permettre la ruche
activer la recherche pour que nous
puissions proposer aux agriculteurs des
produits pour eux pour leur travail tout
en protégeant la santé des gens nicolas
hulot l'écologiste ministre aujourd'hui
on dit ça beaucoup dans la presse a
avalé beaucoup de couleuvres notamment
sur ce cette loi sur projet de loi
agriculture et alimentation à ce qu'il
doit démissionner non alors vraiment moi
je suis à jamais sur des pots des
positions de savoir si untel ou untel
doit démissionner il a dit qu'il allait
réfléchir en juillet août pendant sa
place vous feriez pas la rentrée je suis
pas sa place à on dirait que ça vous
arrange de pas être à sa place c'est
compliqué bah je trouve que c'est quand
y compris quand on est dans un
gouvernement
vous avez été au gouvernement précédent
sous os ou manuel valls et françois
hollande ou ça vous êtes arrivés 12
abandons et là ça marche pas enfin je
sais pas c'est parce que je veux faire
non je franchement j'ai eu le privilège
qu'on peut dire d'arriver sur la période
à laquelle j'étais arrivé alors pour
certains c'est pas un privilège moi j'ai
j'ai appréhendé quand même privilège
parce que ça m'a donné vraiment une très
très grande liberté d'action demandeurs
ça m'a donné une très grande liberté
d'action j'avais la confiance du
président et du premier ministre
c'est vrai que j'ai gagné beaucoup de
deux décisions à l'encontre de mes
collègues donc j'ai pas eu à gérer ce
qu'à gérer aujourd'hui je pense nicolas
hulot donc oui je le verrai serment
sûrement bien vous dirai pas ce que vous
en pensez
votre collègue jean hugues ratenon
députés la france est soumise préconise
un collectif de tous les élus
réunionnais pour protester contre la
hausse des carburants notamment mais
contre la hausse des prix en général des
taxes des impôts etc
il y at il matière à protester et de
quelle manière est ce qu'il peut y avoir
un collectif des élus lyonnais existe
non on a un collectif des députés qui
s'est installée on travaille plutôt bien
pour continuer à creuser des choses mais
on travaille plutôt bien non je suis
très contente que ce soit que ce soit ça
après sur tous les problèmes de vie
chère je crois qu'on a des instances ont
à l'observatoire des prix et des marges
et des revenus
on a une loi la loi régulation
économique outre-mer on a beaucoup
d'outils
je pense que sérieusement les de façon
sérieuse les services
de la préfecture de la concurrence
doivent continuer le travail de façon
acharnée pour que les outils qui sont
prévus dans la loi régulation économique
outre-mer soient mises en oeuvre
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas je
pense qu'il nous manque des effectifs à
la dieccte la direction de la
concurrence pour pouvoir contrôler ce
que les uns et les ans les autres font
je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
continue le combat contre les situations
de monopole et d'oligarchie qui font que
quelquefois en situation de monopole
les prix sont à imposer aux
consommateurs parce que si certains
produits en particulier je pense à
certains produits
et si l'on vous le fait votre casque là
à 100 euros et que vous avez qu'un
vendeur de casque si vos 50 euros mais
qu'on vous le fasse à 100 vous allez
l'acheter si vous en avez besoin
donc toutes ces situations là on a des
outils aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qu'ils y
ont apportées quand même quelques
solutions je pense au numérique il y a
eu des retours de l'autorité de la
concurrence il y a eu des rappels à
l'ordre
et il y a eu des prix qui ont baissé y
compris sur les services bancaires donc
tout ça ce sont des des combats qui se
règlent pas d'un coup il faut des outils
législatifs réglementaires il faut une
administration armé pour y aller il faut
une vraie volonté politique et puis il
faut que des pratiques qui ne sont pas
acceptables cesse vous êtes au sein du
parti socialiste secrétaire national à
la france au cn qui à la croissance
bleue sorte de ministre de l'outre-mer
du parti socialiste vous avez été
ministre de l'outre-mer vous même vous
vous attendez quoi des assises d'un
jardin qui doit rendre son livre bleu
lui aussi tout bleu un thème pas plus
d'outre-mer on parle de blé la mer n'est
pas rose tout ça va être rendu là à la
fin du mois vous en attendez quelque
chose de
de précis une avancée côté on va
attendre le rendu puisque pour l'instant
on n'a pas d'éléments concrets sur ce
qui s'est passé dans les ateliers bien
fou entre les ateliers qui étaient sous
dix ans après démocratique très ouvert
et puis tout d'un coup on va avoir une
loi on al'impression contre les 2 e et
de loi je sais par un et noah n'est pas
prévu il y aura un rendu aura un livre
je ne sais pas s'il y aura une loi
autres maires de ce que j'ai compris il
me semble qu'il va pas y avoir deux lois
outre-mer d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
la ministre d outre-mer qui l'a dit
qu'il aura pas de loi
outre mer mais qu'il y aura un budget ça
c'est normal mais qui leur a un budget
en fonction des conclusions des ateliers
des assises
bon c'est bien parce qu'on a perdu une
année budgétaire quand même puisque
l'année budgétaire 2010 8 bat ça s'est
fait en moins parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de livre bleu mannequin est un livre
bleu on aura peut-être plus de moyens
pour faire ce qu'on a à faire
donc moi je suis vraiment dans le flou
mais je ne suis pas la seule beaucoup
sont dans le flou y compris les
socioprofessionnels qui n'ont pas tous
le retour de ce qui s'est passé dans les
ateliers
donc nous attendons
on va voir ce qu'on dira il ya beaucoup
de sujets au parlement sur les quais de
vous avez communiqué et d'autres qui
vous encore qui vous attendent dans
l'est dans les mois qui viennent
notamment la question de la formation
professionnelle vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure il ya des choses qui se joue qui
sont importantes pour la réunion sur ce
sujet là oui c'est une wasla aussi très
technique
on a des lois très technique mais qui
ont pourtant beaucoup de conséquences
sur la vie des gens ce qui est très
difficile d'expliquer parce que rentrer
dans la tuyauterie s'intéresse personne
pourtant c'est de savoir comment est ce
que mon fils ma fille sera formé comment
moi même en tant que salarié je pourrais
continuer à être formés quand les
métiers vont disent mon métier
disparaîtra ou que je voudrais faire un
autre projet professionnel
donc nous on a eu je me suis intéressé à
cette loi donc j'ai été délégué avec
deux autres collègues de guadeloupe et
martinique par les délégations des
autres maires pour faire ce travail là
on a eu chaud en audition la ministre du
travail
muriel pénicaud et nous nous sommes
interrogés enfin nous avons interrogé la
ministre sur d'une part sur
l'apprentissage vous savez que les
régions vont être affaibli puisque les
régions vont perdre leurs compétences
dans ce domaine n'a d'ailleurs tu vois
transféré aux branches prof voilà donc
je n'ai pas entendu ici la région dire
que c'était grave
j'ai eu hervé morin en audition qui a
dit que lui il trouvait ça très grave
mais bon la réunion ne sont pas très
inquiète par rapport à ça non nous
sommes inquiets pourquoi parce que nous
pensons que on ne peut pas donner
l'avenir de l'apprentissage
exclusivement à des branches on parle
bien d'un développement économique donc
il faut vraiment une coordination et une
discussion entre le pouvoir politique et
le pouvoir économique qui serait
représenté par des branches sauf que à
la réunion nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
branches en est une branche qui est très
structurée c'est la branche du btp mais
sinon nous n'avons très nous avons très
peu de branches comment nous allons
délégué l'apprentissage alors qu'il n'y
a pas de branche ou à part celle du btp
ça c'est un vrai sujet en lui a posé la
question la deuxième chose et là on a
été en force de proposition lui a dit
écoutez nous vous nous dites
vous allez faire pour les jeunes n'a qui
sont dans l'hexagone de l'apprentissage
et de la formation professionnelle en
alternance en tout cas avec les pays de
l'est européen avec les grandes
entreprises etc
mais nous on a 95 96 % des tpe pme très
petites entreprises
comment voulez-vous demander aux très
petites entreprises de recevoir tous les
jeunes de faire de la formation en
alternance de recevoir toutes les
l'insertion des personnes handicapées
et puis nous nous pensons que nos jeunes
ils doivent aller service s'enrichir
dans la mobilité mais pas une mobilité
aller sans retour
il faut proposer le retour est pas une
mobilité hexagonal exclusivement nous
voulons faire une mobilité avec
l'afrique du sud l'inde et ses acteurs
est ce que c'est possible ça et alors
elle m'a dit mme c'est une très bonne
idée
elle me dit si vous proposer un
amendement je regarde avec bienveillance
alors j'ai proposé un amendement et nous
avions su emporter l'unanimité en
commission des affaires sociales pour la
formation professionnelle et pour
l'apprentissage en faisant que demain je
prends un exemple un jeune homme qui
ferait une jeune fille qui ferait on
apprend un apprentissage par exemple
dans l'hôtellerie irait faire un stage
dans un hôtel haut de gamme à l'île
maurice
c'est pas cher c'est prêt environnement
que le chômage touche ou alors nous on a
mis des éléments techniques et la
ministre nous dit que en séance si
nécessaire elle à mandera mon amendement
pour rendre les choses faisable alors il
faut les accords bilatéraux mais les
accords bilatéraux mettra pas ça dans la
loi ça ce sont des choses qui vont être
conclu plus tard mais en tout cas ça a
été voté à l'unanimité en commission des
affaires sociales je pense que l'on
reviendra pas là-dessus comme intermède
musical vous avez choisir et cabaret
marmaille longtemps when the basterds on
l'écouté
[Musique]
à
cet effet
aussi
[Musique]
avec cet été
tu es là pas la maman
[Musique]
l'apa la main
kate dans la quille palin à poupet
gâteau
[Musique]
la bâtisse
elle n'a pas la main
des gâteaux
et allah
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
des mots
souper homard
t mon
m
la faune est entre nous
[Musique]
non
elle a par am
[Musique]
elle a
hamama
et allah
[Musique]
c'était basse-terre maman et longtemps
je suis désolé on voit pas voir
d'écouter en entier je sais qu'à chaque
fois dans cette émission les musiques
c'est pas bien mais en a besoin de temps
pour parler politique
pourquoi ce choix erika barrage en
quelques mots oh c'est une belle
nostalgie je trouve que c'est une c'est
bien dit ça raconte bien la jolie
histoire qui parle à beaucoup de
personnes moi j'aime bien le pied de
tamarin parce que je vois beaucoup de
pieds de tamarin saint denis et je vois
beaucoup de tamarin par terre alors
quand j'étais gamin les gamineries
tamarins restez pas par terre isolée
dans notre poche enfin fr de l'eau
sucrée vraiment avec l'école et on
change
ouais ericka bareigts le retour de
françois hollande sur la scène politico
médiatique c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle pour le ps je sais pas
si il revient sur la scène
médiatique oui et il il est dans la
promotion
de son livre il a fait un livre il est
dans la promotion voilà moi je je veux
voir ça sent quand même que je ne veux
voir que ça et je trouve cela non moi je
trouve que on est donc dans ce travail
qui est ingrat où cette génération envie
de reconstruire quelque chose je trouve
qu' il faut laisser olivier faur
l'équipe donc le nouveau et le nouveau
premier secrétaire je pense qu'il faut
le laisser prendre sa place et faire ce
travail là
le parti socialiste propose aux
sympathisants expliqué que si j'ai bien
compris aux sympathisants de gauche de
participe à l'élaboration du programme
du ps moyennant une participation d'un
euro
c'est ça l'idée pas c'est surtout l'idée
de participer mais pourquoi payer
d'autres d'autres partis ont fait
gratuitement l adhésion gratuite vous
savez si on a toujours eu ce débat il ya
déjà eu des balles as de dire vont c'est
le symbole de se dire on fait ce geste
là ça veut dire que derrière ce geste il
ya une volonté de dial et quoi de faire
je passe ça change énormément entre ceux
qui voudront tricher pour venir nous
donner des mauvaises idées n'ont cessé
vraiment de d'ouvrir la participation la
plus large possible et en même temps le
fait de solliciter en or 11 10 bomba les
gens quand ils mettent un euro ils font
quand même ce geste là donc mais
montrent leur volonté
sincère localement il y aura un appel à
participer à l'élaboration de ce que
doit être le ps je peux enfin être
invité philippe maillet qui n'a de
premier fédéral pourrait changer là
dessus avec vous en tout cas la première
la fédération avec philippe maillet là
lui aussi participent à cette
renaissance et avec des nouvelles
personnes là il a beaucoup enfin il a
renouvelé
il ya des nouveaux visages il ya une
vraie parité plus en plus de jeunes
femmes qui prennent qui prennent le
pouvoir et on est ravi
d'ailleurs d'aider des jeunes femmes qui
ont des responsabilités politiques donc
voilà qui continue à le faire dans party
by à audrey bellini à brigitte et ça
reste compliqué pour dribbler d'aller au
sénat après michel dennemont qui est
très clairement aux marches menant au
drame et nîmes est une jeune femme
talent qu'elle sera en revanche elle
sera elle saura faire ce canon est là
elle n'est pas en marche dans lé parti
socialiste et secrétaire fédéral vous
assumez 7ce cet accord qui a eu pour les
sénatoriales en disant ben voilà on va
avec avec en marche
oui offrant là on l'assumé parce qu'il
est fait
non d'accord pas fier y'a pas être fier
ou pas fier on aura une jeune sénatrice
mme je suis très fier qu'on ait une
jeune sénatrice et qu'elles soient
socialistes et qu'elles portent les
couleurs et elle est engagée audrey est
là elle fait son travail de militants
socialistes sur le terrain en tant qu
élue à la mairie de saint denis et et
elle va continuer au sénat et ça c'est
ça c'est bien parce que vous savez le
renouvellement le renouvellement en
politique ces singes disculpant c'est
pas simple à voir des jeunes femmes
c'est très compliqué non pas qu'elle ne
veuille pas mais tout dans la société
n'est pas fait pour que les femmes
encore s'engage dans la vie politique
donc qu'on vous en avez une
enfin n'en a pas que deux mais là pour
le sénat y en a une qui pourrait être
sénatrice demain moi je suis très
heureuse les prochaines échéances
électorales sur les européennes dans un
an
ouais vous regretté qu'il y ait plus de
circonscription ultramarine il y aura
donc circonscription unique mais ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des élus
ultramarins à condition qu'il soit bien
placé sur les listes
est ce que ça sera le cas pour le ps ça
je ne sais pas mais ce que je sais c'est
que je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas de
circonscription ultramarine d'ailleurs
en s'exprimer là dessus nous on a voté
contre cette proposition de loi parce
que derrière est aussi une stratégie
politique de la république en marche
puisque comme ils n'ont pas d'ancrage
territorial fort forcément avoir une
liste nationale règle le problème de
l'absence d'ancrage territorial savent
que nous dans cette affaire-là en opère
dans l'ancrage territorial on perd la
visibilité des outre-mer en 2020 et dans
les années qui suivent on aura tout
l'art une renégociation avec l'europe de
leur participation sur les fonds de
cohésion sociale sur la pac là on a
plein de deux problématiques très lourde
et peut-être perdre des financements
donc oui peut-être que demain les partis
les uns les autres mettront un
ultramarin et j'espère que le parti
socialiste le fera aussi mais ça ne
réglera pas le problème de la visibilité
et territoires ultramarins dans la
négociation est dans notre
construction européenne l'europe va pas
très bien en ce moment
les eurosceptiques gagne dit megan des
élections un peu partout en europe ça
vous inquiète oui oui beaucoup beaucoup
parce que il y a il y a le sens de la
construction européenne on est dans une
société d'une part de l'immédiateté
alors eu des erreurs bien sûr de
communication de positionnement européen
mais je reste sur le sens on a perdu le
sens de pourquoi la construction
européenne parce qu'on n'est pas de la
génération qui avons connu les guerres
et nous pensons que tout ça est très
théorique et que ça ne peut pas se faire
à nouveau
et pourtant lorsque les peuples n'arrive
pas à s'unir sur des projets humains
sociaux environnementaux et économiques
je mets économique à la fin eh ben on
peut se déchirer pour des intérêts qui
demain nous met en danger et peut amener
à la guerre et à la déchirure donc moi
je crois beaucoup risquent d'être
déchirure de guerre et je crois que la
réponse pour la paix c'est l'union et
c'est l'union européenne alors on l'a
peut-être abordé sûrement même abordé
beaucoup trop sur l'aspect économique et
financier et ça a tué l'idée humaniste
qu'on pouvait se faire du projet
européen et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
on est partis sur des positions
populistes et extrémistes qui nous
mettent en danger par rapport à cette
paix qui a été voulu par les pères
fondateurs l'avenir des rup région ultra
périphérique
c'est aussi une question
constitutionnelle une question qui se
pose aussi au niveau national avec la
réforme constitutionnelle voulue par
emmanuel macron un mot là-dessus sur
l'amendement vient rappeler le
gouvernement dit que si tous les
parlementaires réunionnais vous mettez
tous d'accord alors ça pourrait évoluer
est ce que c'est possible est ce que
vous êtes sur un accord possible
les députés et sénateurs réunionnais va
essayer de travailler dans l'intérêt de
la réunion
moi je les dis il ya moi je ne fais de
procès à personne et certainement pas à
monsieur virapoullé
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est l'avenir la
réunion des réunionnais et d'imaginer
que demain on puisse avoir un outil
supplémentaire à la construction de
notre maison commune m'intéresse plus on
a des outils plus je l'espère la maison
pourra être belle c'est tout ce qui
m'intéresse le texte sur lequel vous
pourriez tous d'accord il dirait quoi
dans le texte qui se seraient hors
confirmer que nous sommes départements
français que dans les régions ça veut
dire on écrit voilà départements et
régions que nous sommes pas sur la
démarche collectivité unique et que nous
souhaitons avoir une possibilité de
pouvoir adapter localement si nous le
souhaitons
dans le cadre des règles de la
république et comme le prévoit la
constitution
certaines règles pour pouvoir ne pas
être en butte à des choses qui nous
empêche de faire les règles qui concerne
les compétences du département la région
mais au delà voilà ça ça existe déjà
mais c'est d'aller au delà
comme il sera prévu semble-t-il pour les
toutes les autres collectivités
hexagonal savait difficile de faire
accepter sa jean paul virapoullé et les
plus lus mais non c'est pas jean paul
virapoullé notre notre souci notre souci
c'est de se mettre d'accord d'aller de
façon apaisée sans faire de procès à
personne de regarder l'intérêt général
de la réunion est de trouver la
meilleure solution pour que nous mêmes
nos enfants et les générations qui
viennent puissent avoir les bons outils
pour construire ce pays parce que c'est
très compliqué on l'a vu tous les enjeux
qui se posent à nous et la réunion n'est
pas sous cloche la réunion est
confrontée à une mondialisation aussi de
plus en plus violentes et il faut qu'on
ait les meilleurs moyens pour affronter
pour cette cette mondialisation et que
nos enfants soient le plus armé possible
notre territoire soit le plus protégé
possible notre économie la plus
florissante possible et notre culture la
plus préservée possible
quelle relation on arrive en toute fin
d'émission ericka bareigts quelles
relations aujourd'hui quelles relations
politiques vous entretenez avec un
gilbert annette qui restait très mac
rognant macro nist vous êtes très
clairement dans une opposition à
l'assemblée nationale comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous travaillez ensemble
très très bien à bien vous êtes d'accord
ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de différence
a nommé nous la mire à la mairie à la
mairie on est absolument complètement
d'accord le développement du projet de
saint denis et on est quand on parle
presque avait dû venir le temps passe
alors quand on parle politique on a
chacun nos positions effectivement lui
il est pas complètement sur ma position
il est socialiste
mais regarde quelques mesures du
président macro de façon positive
certaines normes et certaines oui et moi
j'ai ma position qui est de dire que
quand je regarde les les propositions du
président jusqu'à présent je n'ai vu
aucune
hélas je dis bien hélas qu'ils aillent
dans le bon sens
pour la réunion vous serez aux
prochaines élections d'en parler on a
parlé de l'europe
ensuite c'est 2020-2021 2020 les
municipales 2021 les régionales où est
ce que vous serez à ce moment là
d'accord la réunion ça veut dire par à
paris ça veut dire pas l'assemblée
nationale au bas pour faire campagne il
faut être un peu à la réunion quand même
vous vous ferez campagne pour être à la
mairie de saint denis pour être à la
région qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui
vous tente aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
vous intéresse
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de faire
avancer mes amendements oui d'accord
mais enfin bon plus précisément je
reviendrai vous parlez bon merci
beaucoup et les cabanes avec nous ce
soir dans quelques minutes ce sera les
infos puis elodie qui vous accompagne
ensuite
et puis demain matin on va parler d'un
sujet qui vous intéressera certainement
ericka bareigts des centres
d'information et d'orientation sont
menacés de fermeture
le collectif éternellement le collectif
des psychologues de l'éducation
nationale manifesteront demain matin
devant le rectorat 8h30 et
marie-christine donné hier porte parole
de ce collectif répondre aux questions
de philippe dornier à partir de 7 heures
c'est merci beaucoup merci